[Music]
on this Thursday night pandemic
projections for Canada the possible
outcomes from best case to worst case it
depends on what each of us does right
now
staggering job losses Canada's worst
monthly numbers ever what's happening
inside long-term care homes serious
concerns about what's fueling the spread
it is absolutely a perfect storm headed
directly for disaster as residents keep
dying in care homes across the country
managing our mental health in melancholy
times they have no idea of what the
long-term plan is even with the short
term plan is some ideas on how to pierce
the gloom
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
it's only been 100 days since the first
reports of a deadly new virus emerged in
China and look where we are almost every
aspect of our life has changed in every
corner of the world almost 100 thousand
people have died and billions are living
under lockdown today Canada's Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau told Canadians
to brace themselves for a long road
ahead our health care systems across the
country are coping for the time being
but we're at a fork in the road between
the best and the worst possible outcomes
the initial peak the top of the curve
may be in late spring with the end of
the first wave in the summer there will
likely be smaller outbreaks for a number
of months after that this will be the
new normal until a vaccine is developed
the new normal that projection is based
on new disease modeling that was
released today these are projections not
certainties in the worst case scenario
if Canada had done nothing the federal
model projects 300,000 people could have
died putting in all the public health
measures physical distancing shutting
down non-essential businesses asking
people to stay home has slowed the
spread but a rise in deaths is still
expected even with tight restrictions
staying in place its projected between
11,000 to 22,000 people in Canada could
die we cannot prevent every death but we
must prevent all the deaths that we can
we all play a role in what the future
will hold for Canada's kovat 19
trajectory we must continue to control
the epidemic using tried-and-true public
health measures the best possible
outcome is what everyone of course wants
but the path to get there will not be
easy in our top story tonight Mike look
at or takes us through the projections
and how our behavior has a direct impact
on what happens next
on the anniversary of Vimy Ridge Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau continued to
call on Canadians to do their part in
the battle against kovat 19 over a
hundred years ago today
Canadians showed what metal we are made
of
I know each of us will rise to be worthy
of the legacy of the heroes that built
this country an inspiring message on a
day where Canadians face some sobering
stats from public health officials the
most reliable forecasts only look at the
short-term but even those numbers are
grim based on the case fatality rate to
date this could mean we reach between
500 and 700 total deaths in Canada by
next week Canada's top doctor presented
three scenarios one with no epidemic
controls a second with some controls
like physical distancing and the third
where strong controls were used
that's where Canada is now officials
just aren't sure how far along the line
we are you can't tell whether you reach
the peak until after the peak had
actually been realized officials also
compared Canada to the rest of the world
showing we're right in the middle of the
pack the good news is that kovat 19 hit
our shores later than others allowing us
to learn from other countries and not
repeat their mistakes like ordering
physical distancing early and extending
it for the foreseeable future on the
downward trend on the other side of the
curve it'll be equally critical to keep
up with our control measures if we let
up new chains of transmission will take
off in our highly susceptible population
and the epidemic will reignite the
government is mindful of that while at
the same time is trying to give
businesses a little bit of hope and we
are extremely hopeful that we will be
able to begin to restore a certain
measure of economic activity in the
coming months after this first wave his
past but even before that happens the
government has to pass the wage subsidy
program to help keep Canadians employed
and late today we learned the House of
Commons will hold a special Saturday
sitting to do just that Donna Mike look
at Orion Ottawa thank you we knew
closing all non-essential businesses
would hit hard today new numbers are
showing how hard at least 1 million
people in Canada lost their jobs in
March and
precedented number pushing the
unemployment rate to 7.8 percent the
service industry has been hardest hit
and as Eric Sorenson explains the impact
affects every corner of the country the
restaurants are empty small businesses
shut down hotels without guests shopping
centers cleared out and on and on more
than any other sector the service
industry has been decimated by the
pandemic of the million jobs lost nine
hundred sixty-three thousand were in the
service industries retail wholesale
full-time part-time the unemployment
rate for the country jumped two point
two percent the largest one-month
increase on record this is a huge
economic shock and it is going to cause
a contraction in the economy and then
we're going to see the the employment
effects of that as well
unprecedented job loss but jobs not lost
forever we're asking people to basically
shut down temporarily this isn't
necessarily permanent jobs lost its
temporary jobs being displaced
thanks to covin nineteen to put a loss
of 1 million jobs in perspective the
previous high was 125,000 jobs in the
historic recession of 2009 the
difference in magnitude is stunning
the unemployment jolt was felt across
the country almost 50,000 jobs were lost
in Atlantic Canada more than 260,000 in
Quebec over 400,000 in Ontario another
160,000 across the three prairie
provinces most of them in Alberta and
then a hundred and thirty thousand plus
in BC no region was spared in the
hard-hit service sector across the
country some groups are
disproportionately affected women young
workers vulnerable workers in low-paying
jobs and the numbers only reflect the
beginning of the pandemic a month from
now
1 million job losses could be 2 million
and yet it would be worse but for the
stimulus from Ottawa and other
governments emergency benefits going to
millions of Canadians they actually
can't stop the economic contraction but
they can certainly temper how bad it is
and they can also help stage the
recovery that we expect later in the
year federal dollars prompted WestJet
like Air Canada to put thousands back on
the payroll and Ontario one of the first
striking new jobs in recovery committee
injecting some economic optimism we will
come back stronger and more United than
ever before not just looking for light
but trying to create light at the end of
the tunnel
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto in the
u.s. a decade of job growth has vanished
in less than a month six point six
million Americans filed applications for
unemployment benefits last week that
brings the total who lost their jobs in
one month to more than 17 million it's
predicted that could rise to more than
20 million by the end of April thirteen
percent of Americans are now out of work
the most since the Great Depression
today the US Federal Reserve announced
another two point three trillion dollars
in loans that includes support for
states cities and municipalities they
already struggling oil and gas industry
in this country is trying to plan for a
long slow climb out of disaster
Alberta's premier warns they'll soon be
paying for companies to take Alberta oil
that wasn't helped when last month
OPEC ramped up production causing oil
prices to crash to record lows today oil
producers held a video conference to
discuss a production cut heather Eurex
west explains as members of the world's
largest oil cartel met via
videoconference Thursday Canadian oil
producers could only wait with bated
breath in the oil and gas industry we've
been particularly hit hard because we've
had a complete crippling of commodity
prices with oil prices hitting record
low was more than eight billion dollars
worth of investment into Alberta's
energy sector has been scrapped job
losses have followed the reality is that
no one is buying oil and the world is
running out of places to put it it's why
a production cut now by OPEC and its
allies is so critical Alberta's premier
warns that at current rates every square
inch of storage in North America will be
full within four to six weeks I don't
need to tell you how catastrophic that
would be for our industry should that
occur that's the kind of negative price
scenario that I I floated with Albertans
on Tuesday night but analysts warn even
an historic production cut of 10 million
barrels per day or more will not be
enough to get
energy sector out of this crisis while
it is essential that we do have
production cuts to help stabilize the
market this more is more likely to
guarantee a price floor and help buy
time for all producers including Alberta
it's why the industry continues to press
the federal government for help
Ottawa announced plans for a 15 billion
dollar bailout last month two weeks ago
the federal finance minister said
details were hours away but since then
nothing Mark Schultz says livelihoods
are at stake we will see casualties no
question and I think it will then the
number will be determined by how much
federal support we get and that really
is where we're at today Heather your ex
west global news Calgary we know this
virus is especially dangerous for older
people and in Canada the biggest
outbreaks have been in long-term care
homes in Ontario alone there are
outbreaks in at least 69 homes and at
least 88 residents have died one place
we're watching closely as Almonte
country Haven west of Ottawa 10
residents there have died since March
29th because of complications from Kovan
19 a statement from the home says in
addition to those deaths 20 other
residents have tested positive families
say they were kept in the dark for more
than a week about what was happening I
know they've done everything they can to
to try to stop it and but we're you know
it's a small resident there are many
many rooms that are multiple residents
living in rooms so you know shared rooms
so it's you know it's a very difficult
thing to contain those who run the home
say they put new precautions in place
including isolating residents in their
rooms and ensuring staff wear full
protective equipment at all times
Ontario's premier has demanded more
testing be done in that province and
today the scope of who is eligible for a
test was expanded the provinces chief
medical health officer says vulnerable
people including caregivers and
residents and long-term care homes and
frontline health care workers will get
tested that includes those who develop
symptoms even a typical ones anyone
newly admitted to a long-term care home
as well as residents who have been in
contact with a confirmed case
and people living in remote indigenous
communities should be tested if they
display symptoms in 2006 after the SARS
outbreak Canadian health officials
created the Canadian pandemic influenza
plan it called for governments to
stockpile everything from ventilators to
n95 masks gowns gloves and face shields
supplies that are now in short supply
one of the authors of that report was
dr. Teresa Tam who is now the country's
chief public health officer today she
was asked if Canada underestimated the
severity of this virus and the need for
medical supplies we're in a global but
that seems a global supply shortage
situation for almost everything that we
need so I can certainly attest the fact
that everybody is pulling out all stops
and that is part of our role is not to
just stop pass stuff in a lot of places
but pull together the mechanism so that
there is access from the UK tonight a
bit of positive news to report coming up
an update on the health of Britain's
Prime Minister
we're keeping an eye on the rest of the
world tonight let's look at the global
numbers now there are close to 1.6
million people known to have kovat 19
more than 95,000 people have died the UK
recorded 881 deaths today new research
shows that country could be the hardest
hit in Europe scientists with the
Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation say Britain could have more
than 65,000 deaths by August there is a
bit of good news out of the UK prime
minister Boris Johnson is now out of
intensive care the 55 year old has kovat
19 he's still in the hospital under
close observation he was admitted on
Sunday in the US there hasn't been a
spike in hospitalizations in New York
State today but there has been a
record-breaking increase in deaths for a
third consecutive day and now contract
laborers have been hired to bury the
dead on Hart island in potter's field
that's where New Yorkers with no known
next of kin have been laid to rest since
the 19th century 24 bodies are being
buried every day five days a week
experts hand in their homework ahead
answers to kids
Kovac 19 questions
we know Kovac 19 has caused uncertainty
around the world of course what's
happening right now can be hard for US
adults to understand it's even tougher
for children so tonight we're trying to
alleviate some of their concerns
Jeff sample is taking questions from
kids right across the country to the
experts Breanna and Bryson Rose have
been stuck at home for weeks doing
crafts to keep busy and they like a lot
of kids have a lot of questions go to
like kids immune systems are usually
pretty great at fighting the virus but
their parents and grandparents are at a
greater risk so we need you at home to
stay home for now and keep away from
your friends and relatives until the
outbreak has gotten under control many
kids also want to know more about the
virus how did Coby maintains that health
experts think the virus started in a bat
in China from China even get co19
anyways bats can carry a lot of
different viruses without getting sick
the more clothes that we get to to
animals and the more that we disturb
their habitat and go where they are the
easier it is for us to get viruses that
we didn't know about the form kovat 19
spreads through coughing and sneezing it
can survive on something like a plastic
toy for up to three days the virus
doesn't jump so it doesn't go from a toy
into your nose the only way it can guess
is if you touch it and then touch your
mouth and nose and that's why washing
your hand and not touching your mouth
nose is so important is there any way to
find out if I have already been infected
with : 19 and recovered and not even
knowing it doctors in Toronto have
actually just developed a blood test to
determine if you've had the virus those
people are not likely to get infected
again and for everyone else Brianna
bricen have a message what does that say
stay safe
Jeff simple Global News Toronto
psychology in a pandemic next we check
in on Canadians mental health mental
health is a big issue for so many people
right now there's so much fear and
uncertainty and anxiety we don't know
when things will return to normal today
Canada's Health Minister had some
reassuring words for Canadians this is a
time for us to pull together as
Canadians we can all call those people
that we know are struggling or maybe
even those that we're not thinking or
struggling to say that we're thinking of
them it's always good to reach out as
we're all a part but together might role
a looks at the research tracking
Canada's state of mind with spring in
the air life is getting ready to blossom
in Toronto's Hyde Park every year
thousands gather to take in the sights
and smells of the flowering trees but in
our new kovat nineteen world anybody who
shows up will be met with the
Yellowjackets of bylaw officers in
physical distance only stinks it's
starting to stress us out it's that
anxiety researchers at Wilfrid Laurier
University are trying to measure during
this pandemic what they found after one
week in isolation was that while 40% of
participants were feeling anxious or
nervous nearly every day those who had
been laid off were having a much harder
time than people working from home in
fact breaking down the numbers even more
30 percent of laid off workers report
they're feeling depressed nearly every
day some people are reporting that they
find it hard at the psychological or
almost existent level to make sense of
what's happening they feel conflicted
they don't understand what
in their life motivating ourselves to
get active is proving to be difficult as
well with 67% happy to do activities
most days other research suggests to get
out of our doldrums we should be taking
cues from the women in our lives is
higher which is interesting higher in
women than in men now we would have
thought the opposite because women are
more likely to be single parents and
things like that and but we are seeing
perhaps because women tend to have
better social networks or what have you
with so much uncertainty in the future
connecting with others will be important
in the weeks and months to come
microlight Global News Toronto and that
is global national for this Thursday I'm
Donna Friesen as we keep you informed
about this pandemic I'll be hosting a
special program on global on Sunday
evenings join me for coronavirus the new
reality it starts this Sunday at 7:00
p.m. and we leave you now with an
inspiring challenge for Canadians that's
just the warmup every Sunday at noon
we're starting a nationwide sing-along
dedicated to our frontline workers you
can share your version of o-canada using
the hashtag Canada together thanks for
watching take care of yourself bye bye
strong and free money suave to new